sechs Jahre und einen Tag nach dem
deutschen Überfall auf Polen
unterzeichnet Japan am zweiten september
1945 die Kapitulationsurkunde
der Zweite Weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele Menschen in diesem Krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen
ebenso wenig den Namen des ersten oder
den des letzten Opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind Menschen die in diesem
Krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären Panzer nicht gerollt
Flugzeuge nicht geflogen
und Schiffe nicht gefahren
im Krieg geht es um Menschen mit
oder ohne Uniform
[Musik]
Menschen in Städten
Dörfern Wäldern
Verbündete Fremde
[Musik]
verfeindete Nachbarn
hunderte Millionen Menschen
die sechs Jahre und einen Tag lang
die Hölle auf Erden durchlebten
[Musik]
Hitler will in der Sowjetunion bis zur
sogenannten aa-linie vorstoßen
streckte sich von archangels gambeißen
mehr bis nach Astrachan am Kaspischen
Meer wer sich westlich dieser Linie
befand wurde versklavt oder getötet
im Frühling 1942 will Hitler die
Offensive fortsetzen die Frau Moskau zum
Erliegen gekommen war er will bis zur
aa-linie vorstoßen bis in den Kaukasus
und bis nach Stalingrad
[Musik]
im Frühjahr 1942 kontrollieren die
Achsenmächte mehr als ein Drittel der
Weltbevölkerung und der Bodenschätze auf
der Erde
doch das Blatt beginnt sich zu wenden
um das Jahr 1942 zu verstehen ist es
wichtig festzuhalten dass die Deutschen
die Sowjets 1941 nicht besiegen konnten
im März 1942 sind 51 deutsche Divisionen
in Westeuropa stationiert
167 kämpfen an der Ostfront hinzu kommen
weitere Truppen der Achsenmächte und
ihrer Verbündeten Ende Juni 1942 schickt
Hitler sie in die nächste Schlacht
Codename Unternehmen blau
doch wie will man 1942 erfolgreich sein
wo man schon 1941 mit mehr Ressourcen
scheiterte
Hitler geht das Problem ökonomisch an er
startet Unternehmen blau so der Name der
Sommeroffensive 1942 um sich
kriegswichtige Bodenschätze wie Öl im
Süden Russlands zu sichern
italien hatte Unternehmen Barbarossa
1941 mit 62.000 Soldaten unterstützt als
Unternehmen Blaus startet erhöht
Mussolini seine Truppen auf 230.000 sie
positionieren sich zwischen der zweiten
ungarischen und der dritten rumänischen
Armee damit ein bestehender Zwist bei
der Nationen nicht eskaliert
General feldmarsch alfidor von Bock soll
die Offensive der Heeresgruppe Süd
anführen um den Kaukasus mit seinen
ergiebigen Ölquellen zu erobern
[Musik]
im Unternehmen blau mussten die Truppen
eine Distanz von 500 Kilometern
zurücklegen von der Ostukraine bis nach
Stalingrad
aber Stalingrad ist nur das Tor zum
Kaukasus von dort sind es nochmal 300
Kilometer bis in den Kaukasus
[Musik]
im Frühjahr 1942 hat die elfte Armee der
Wehrmacht bereits weite Teile der Krim
besetzt
am 12 Mai startet die Rote Armee unter
Marschall Sammy und Timoschenko südlich
von Krakow eine Gegenoffensive
ziel ist die Einschließung der sechsten
deutschen Armee unter General Friedrich
Paulus doch es kommt anders
der russische Präventivschlag mündete in
einer Katastrophe
Paulus sechster Armee sowie
Panzerverbände der Armeegruppe von
Kleist Kesseln die rotaristen ein
240.000 Sowjetsoldaten werden gefangen
genommen etwa 1.250 Panzer und mehr als
2000 Geschütze zerstört oder erbeutet
die deutsche Offensive nimmt Fahrt auf
im zweiten Jahr des Ostfeldzugs fehlten
den deutschen die Ressourcen für eine
komplette frontoffensive also entschied
man sich für eine Sommeroffensive im
Süden
[Musik]
deutsche und ungarische Truppen starten
zunächst eine offensive östlich von Kurs
am 6 juli erobern sie Woche
beginnt die zweite Phase der deutschen
Offensive
das Ziel Rosdorf am Don
nachdem die Rote Armee im Süden
zerschlagen wird befiehlt Hitler am 23
juli die Heeresgruppe Süd aufzuteilen
Generalstabschef Franz Halder nennt die
Entscheidung in seinem Tagebuch
haarsträubend und gefährlich
Hitler eine der Eigenschaften die Hitler
zu einem erfolgreichen Anführer machte
war sein unerschütterlicher Glaube an
sich selbst den stets begleitete
Menschen die sich alles selbst
beibringen haben immer etwas
Beängstigendes Autodidakten mit
wahnhaften Ideen wie auch Mussolini oder
Stalin sind extrem gefährlich
notiert auch
die immer schon vorhandene
Unterschätzung der feindlichen
Möglichkeiten nimmt allmählich groteske
Formen an
die eine Hälfte der Truppen sollte zu
den Ölfeldern im Kaukasus im Süden des
Landes marschieren um Russlands
Industrieland zu legen und die
Treibstoffversorgung zu kappen
[Musik]
am 16 juli sucht Hitler das
Führerhauptquartier Werwolf auf seine
neue Kommandozentrale in der Westukraine
von hier aus wird der Kaukasus Vorstoß
Deckname Operation Edelweiß organisiert
die Heeresgruppe A soll entlang der
Schwarzmeerküste bis zu den erdölstädten
Mai Coop Grosny und barkow-vorstoßen
in zwölf Tagen legt sie über 550
Kilometer zurück
[Musik]
die Heeresgruppe B soll im Rahmen von
Operation Fischreiher nach Stalingrad
ziehen
die Wolga Stadt mit ihrem wichtigen
Hafen ist uns mittlerweile wohl vertraut
Stalingrad ist der Stolz der jungen
Russen es ist ihre Stadt erbaut während
ihrer Zeit
[Musik]
am 9 August besetzt von Kleists erste
panzerarmee die Ölfelder bei microb
am 21 August überquert die sechste Armee
den Don und beginnt mit ihrem Vormarsch
auf Stalingrad
[Applaus]
als die deutschen Panzer vorrücken
bringt die Rote Armee ihre Flagge
Schütze in Stellung
viele werden von jungen Frauen und
Abiturientinnen bedient kaum eine von
ihnen wird überleben
rund eine Million Frauen dienten in der
Roten Armee
490.000 von ihnen kämpfen an der Front
allein 2500 erhalten eine
scharfschützenausbildung sie sind den
männlichen Soldaten formell
gleichgestellt nur dass sie 100 Gramm
mehr Seife erhalten
die deutschen warfen an einem Tag mehr
als 1000 Tonnen Bomben über der Stadt ab
Ende sedr the same
400.000 Menschen und allein in der
ersten Woche starben 40.000
Stalins Befehl Nummer 227 lautet
schlicht nicht einen Schritt zurück
und weiter
Miesmacher und Feiglinge müssen auf der
Stelle vernichtet werden
[Musik]
der Westen verweist immer wieder auf das
totalitäre Regime das alle Angst hatten
das hinter jedem ein bewaffneter Soldat
steht aber das stimmt nicht es ist
schlicht unmöglich dass so viele auf
ihre eigenen Mitbürger schießen
in der Schlacht um Stalingrad werden
13.000 rotaristen exekutiert Wegen
fahren Flucht oder Feigheit vor dem
Feind
bevor sie erschossen werden müssen sie
ihre Uniform ablegen denn die müssen
wiederverwendet werden und sollten
möglichst keine Einschusslöcher
aufweisen
Personalpolitik und sein Regierungsstil
waren vor allem eines gnadenlos
Stalin macht auch Zugeständnisse wenn es
ihm nützt einige Kirchen werden wieder
eröffnet und erstmals seit der
Revolution werden Offiziere wieder mit
ihrem Dienstgrad angesprochen aus
Großbritannien lässt sich die UdSSR
einen großen Posten Gold treffen liefern
dabei geht es laut Stalin nicht nur um
die Auszeichnung sondern um Ordnung und
Disziplin
zuerst je länger der Krieg dauerte desto
mehr Entscheidungsspielraum dies Stalin
seiner militärischen Führung Hitler
machte das Gegenteil
am 23 August erreicht eine
Vorausabteilung der 16 panzerdivision
den nördlichsten Vorort von Stalingrad
als die deutschen Soldaten auf einer
Einrichtung für geistig behinderte
Kinder stoßen erschießen sie sämtliche
Insassen
sie sind zwischen 10 und 14 Jahre alt
ganz offensichtlich war das Motto der
deutschen das in dieser Schlacht keine
Tabus mehr galten
am 27 August ernennt Stalin den
46-Jährigen Schuhmacher Sohn general
Georgi Schukow zum stellvertretenden
Oberbefehlshaber der Roten Armee sein
Auftrag die Verteidigung Stalingrad
der Soldat lefkasjevic stand unter
seinem Kommando
der Kirche
wir fuhren mit dem Zug bis nach kamishii
weiter ging es nicht weil die Gleise
völlig zerstört waren gesprungen
die restlichen 100 Kilometer bis nach
Stalingrad mussten wir laufen
das war im August 1942
die marschierten nur nachts weil die
Deutschen tagsüber alles bombardierten
was ich bewegte
[Applaus]
am 2 September notiert general Halder
nach einer Lagebesprechung mit Hitler
dass beim Eindringen in die Stadt die
gesamte männliche Bevölkerung beseitigt
werden soll das Stalingrad mit seiner
eine Million zählenden
durchwegkommunistischen Einwohnerschaft
besonders gefährlich sein
[Musik]
die weibliche Bevölkerung wiederum solle
man abtransportieren wohin sagt er nicht
der Duisburger Schriftsteller Willi
Peter Reese ist an der
ostfrontstationiert zweimal wird er
verwundet er er 1944 in Weißrussland
fällt
1942 schreibt er die Juden ermordet als
brüllende Horde nach Russland marschiert
die Menschen geknebelt im Blut der
gesäbelt vom klaune geführt sind wir die
gesamten des Alberts bekannten und
warten in Blut
[Musik]
am 12 September bestellt Hitler
Friedrich Paulus in das
Führerhauptquartier Werwolf nah wie
Nizza ein und verlangt die Einnahme
Stalingrads
am 13 September beginnt der Angriff auf
die Innenstadt
am 14 september wird der Hauptbahnhof
fünf Mal erobert und wieder
zurückerobert
auch in den folgenden Tagen bleibt der
Bereich um den Hauptbahnhof hart
umkämpft
große Teile der sechsten Armee und der
vierten panzerarmee befanden sich in
Stalingrad die Russen leisteten
erbitterten Widerstand
Anfang Oktober bereiten die deutschen
einen Großangriff auf das Traktorenwerk
zerschinski vor am 14 oktober ist es
soweit
300 Sturzkampfbomber unterstützen den
Infanterie Angriff der Wehrmacht ein
deutscher Offizier beschreibt den Kampf
es war ein zermürbender Kampf auf und
unter der Erde in den Trümmern Kellern
und Kanälen
eine erbitterte gnadenlose Schlacht
beginnt um jedes Stockwerk um jeden Raum
die Deutschen sprechen vom rattenkrieg
Stalingrad liegt in Trummer doch die
Stadt hält sich an den durchhalte Befehl
hitler hat seine ganze Streitmacht hier
konzentriert doch die Russen kämpfen um
jeden Zentimeter
der größte Fehler der deutschen war es
Panzer und so viele Truppen in die Stadt
zu verlegen man musste zwar auf die
russische defensivaktion reagieren aber
es war die falsche Strategie Truppen in
die Stadt zu schicken
Menschen
war herausragend doch leider zählte der
einzelne Soldat in der Sowjetunion nicht
viel Auto ist wahrscheinlich dachte man
dass die vielen Frauen im riesigen
Russland ohnehin genügend Soldaten
gebären
und ob dienen überleben oder nicht war
für die Offiziere sekundär sie schickten
sie einfach ins Gemetzel
allein zwischen dem 13 und 17 Oktober
sterben rund 12.000 rotaristen in der
Schlacht ums Traktorenwerk
Hitler ist überzeugt dass die Rote Armee
schon bald einknicken wird
German die Deutschen wollten die Stadt
komplett auslöschen doch dabei entstehen
Trümmer und wie sich bereits mehrfach
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs zeigte
sind die häufig ein Problem für die
Angreifer vor allem wenn man auf Panzer
und Mauern als Schutz vertraut
[Musik]
am 8 November auf dem Höhepunkt der
Schlacht um Stalingrad hält Hitler eine
Rede im Münchner Löwenbräukeller er sagt
ich sehe gerade heute mit einer großen
Zuversicht in die Zukunft
[Musik]
doch dazu hat er wenig Grund
zwar erreichen deutsche Truppen am 11
November endlich das Ufer der Wolga
doch auf der anderen Flussseite stehen
eine Million rotaristen in Reserve dazu
979 Panzer
14.000 Geschütze und 1350 Flugzeuge
tagsüber hielten wir uns versteckt
schließlich handelte sich um eine
militärische Geheimoperation die
deutschen ahnten nichts davon sie
merkten auch nicht dass der Moment nahte
an dem wir die deutsche Armee
vollständig umzingeln würden
am 19 November 1943 ging es dann los
was passiert
-50 Grad
das war ein so kalter Winter im Dezember
und Januar dass man sich kaum bewegen
konnte
wir ließen die Motoren der Panzer laufen
weil sie Wärme produzierten
uns auf diese Weise neben den
Auspuffrohren auf aber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am Morgen des 19 November den Russland
noch heute als Tag der Artillerie feiert
starten die Sowjets eine große
Gegenoffensive
[Musik]
13.541a Telering Geschütze feuern aus
allen Rohren es ist der Beginn von
Operation Uranus
unsere Artillerie machte sich bereit und
dann nahmen wir die deutschen Stellungen
30 Minuten lang unter Feuer ohne
Unterbrechung
die Katjuscha genannten Raketenwerfer
feuerten Salven ab
sie waren lauter als alles was wir
jemals gehört hatten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einige weinten vor Glück endlich nun
werden wir doch nicht verlieren
verstehen Sie
[Musik]
wir rückten weiter vor immer weiter
innerhalb von 24 Stunden geraten 65.000
rumänische Soldaten in Gefangenschaft
die Russen nutzten eine Schwachstelle in
der deutschen Verteidigungslinie aus und
zwar die Verbündeten ungarischen und
rumänischen Truppen die die sechste
Armee verstärkten und
20 November eröffnet die Rote Armee
südlich von Stalingrad eine weitere
Front ziel ist eine Einkesselung der
deutschen Truppen am 21 November
empfiehlt Paulus den Rückzug zum Don
doch Hitlers Befehl ist eindeutig
durchhalten um jeden Preis
die sechste Armee rund 250.000 Soldaten
sowie 30.000 Verbündete Truppen werden
auf einer Fläche von 40 x 50 km
eingekesselt
am 22 November sind die Truppen komplett
eingeschlossen
[Musik]
Paulus bittet um Erlaubnis zum Ausbruch
doch Hitler lehnt ab daraufhin befiehlt
Paulus sollen wir jetzt den Widerstand
aufgeben unter keinen Umständen wir
müssen um jeden fußbreitboden kämpfen
und dem Russen Schaden zufügen wo wir
können haltet aus die eingekesselten
üben sich in Zweckoptimismus unter den
Soldaten macht ein Vers die Runde
drum haltet aus der Führer haut euch
raus
installingrad live Micke das Leben in
Stalingrad wurde zunehmend schwierig
viele deutsche Soldaten starben nicht
nur im Kampf sondern auch wegen der
extremen Kälte und der schlechten
Versorgung mit Lebensmitteln lecker
[Musik]
so ich bekamin ode you
am 12 dezember starten die deutschen das
Unternehmen Wintergewitter das Ziel den
Ring um die sechste Armee aufzubrechen
um die eingekesselten Truppen zu
befreien doch der Kampf gegen die
dreifach überlegene Rote Armee ist
aussichtslos auch die achte italienische
Armee und die dritte rumänische Armee
können den Sowjets nichts entgegensetzen
sie werden vernichtend geschlagen
kämpften für ihr Land die Italiener aber
kämpften für nichts sie wurden geholt um
den deutschen bei der Eroberung
Russlands zu helfen man hatte sie aus
ihren italienischen Paradiesen in den
Schnee getrieben für sie war es eine
Tragödie
am 23 Dezember einen Tag vor Weihnachten
wird Unternehmen Wintergewitter
abgebrochen
es war der vierten panzerarmee nicht
gelungen einen Korridor für die noch 60
km entfernte sechste Armee zu öffnen
die Aussicht auf Erfolg war ohnehin
gering gewesen zum einen gab es nicht
genug funktionstüchtige
Transportflugzeuge außerdem wollte
Hitler der sechsten Armee nicht die
Erlaubnis für einen Ausbruchsversuch
erteilen
der Nachschub wird knapp
die jahrmini braucht du jeden Tag 700
Tonnen Nachschub Minimum waren 500
Tonnen die Hälfte davon in vielen auf
Lebensmittel darüber hinaus brauchte man
Munition und weiteres Material
tatsächlich kamen jedoch nur 85 Tonnen
an
am 8 Januar bietet general rokosowski
Paulus die ehrenvolle Kapitulation an
doch Hitler will davon nichts wissen
verbietet Kapitulation die Armee hält
ihre Position bis zum letzten Soldaten
und zur letzten Patrone
Paulus fügt sich Hitlers Willen und
lehnt das Ultimatum ab
am nächsten Tag erteilt rokosowski den
Befehl zum Angriff
war klug und gut ausgebildet und seine
Kriegsstrategie war effektiver
[Applaus]
am 10 januar 1943 starten mehr als
200.000 rotaristen und mehr als 250
Panzer mit der Operation calzow zu
deutschring einen letzten Angriff auf
den Kessel am 22 meldet Paulus über Funk
Truppe ohne Munition und Verpflegung
weitere Verteidigung sinnlos
am 24 Januar nimmt die Rote Armee das
letzte deutsche Flugfeld ein und damit
auch die letzte Hoffnung auf Nachschub
die sechste Armee ist besiegt Goebbels
muss die Hiobsbotschaft und das Volk
bringen er sagt
Stalingrad war und ist der große
Alarmruf des Schicksals an die deutsche
Nation ein Volk das die Stärke besitzt
ein solches Unglück zu ertragen und auch
zu überwinden ist unbesiegbar
[Musik]
dayturn into am See machten sie zum
Märtyrern um die Realität der
verheerenden Niederlage der sechsten
Armee zu verschleiern doch jedem war
klar dass dies ein Wendepunkt war
nach dem ständigen Höllenlärm der
Geschütze der Granaten und der Bomben
herrschte jetzt überall Stille
[Musik]
die Schlacht war geschlagen die Waffen
ruhten es herrschte absolute Stille ein
ungewohnter Zustand
[Musik]
Ende Januar 1943 befördert Hitler Paulus
zum Generalfeldmarschall er hofft dass
dieser statt sich zu ergeben den
verklausulierten Hinweis versteht und
den heldenhaften freitodwelt doch Paulus
Tod ihm diesen Gefallen nicht sondern
kapituliert als Hitler von der
Gefangennahme seines Oberbefehlshabers
erfährt tobt er der Mann hat sich tot zu
schießen
doch Paulus sieht das anders
[Musik]
wegen dieses böhmischen gefallen schieße
ich mir doch keine Kugel in den Kopf
storn und Grad war die letzte Schlacht
die auf Augenhöhe geschlagen wurde
danach war das Verhältnis 2:1 gegen
Deutschland das Gleichgewicht der Kräfte
dass man an der Ostfront gebraucht hätte
gab es nicht mehr
[Musik]
Anzahl der deutschen insoweitischer
Kriegsgefangenschaft anbetrifft so
differieren die Zahlen 91.000 98.000
101.102000 mit Sicherheit weiß man nur
dass 1955 als die letzten Soldaten der
sechsten Armee wieder nach Deutschland
zurückkehrten nicht einmal mehr 6000
davon übrig waren
[Musik]
in Gedenken an die Gefallenen von
Stalingrad spielt der deutsche
reichsrundfunk das Adagio aus Bruckner 7
Sinfonie
[Musik]
1945 wird es ein weiteres Mal erklingen
nach der Meldung von Hitlers Tod
[Musik]
auch nach der Niederlage in Stalingrad
kontrollieren die Achsenmächte noch
immer Teile der Sowjetunion mit ihren
Millionen von Einwohnern es wird noch
fast anderthalb Jahre dauern bis die
Invasoren vollends vertrieben sind
Stirling Grad war ein grandioser Sieg
für die Rote Armee doch noch standen die
deutschen Truppen tief in der
Sowjetunion die Vorstellung dass die
Rote Armee sie eines Tages bis nach
Berlin zurückdrängen würde war damals
noch ein ferner Traum
Stalingrad ist nach Stalingrad machten
immer mehr Deutsche Hitler persönlich
für den negativen Kriegsverlauf
verantwortlich klappt
sie nahmen nicht andere hochrangige
Nazis inhaftung oder die Umstände sie
zeigten mit dem Finger auf Hitler als
Urheber dieser Katastrophe
doch nicht nur die vernichtende
Niederlage im fernen Stalingrad
untergräbt die Moral der deutschen
es ist vor allem die Zerstörung der
heimischen Städte
hatte man zu Kriegsbeginn noch die
Hoffnung dass die bombardance strikten
Regeln folgen würden so änderte sich das
spätestens am 24 August 1940 als
deutsche Flugzeuge anstatt
flugzeugfabriken irrtümlich die
britische Hauptstadt bombardieren
es sind die ersten Bomben die auf London
fallen
Winston Churchill ist überzeugt dass es
sich um einen geplanten Angriff handelt
und befiehlt einen Vergeltungsschlag auf
Berlin
Arthur Harris leitet den Angriff
Winstons Haltung war bombardieren was
das Zeug hält
Churchill wünschte sich
einen absolut verheerenden vernichtenden
Angriff mit schweren Bombern auf die
Heimat der Nazis
dann Studien des britischen Militärs und
des Innenministeriums kamen zu dem
Schluss dass die Gesellschaft
zusammenbrechen und die Menschen in
Panik geraten würden wenn Ihre
wichtigsten Zentren bombardiert werden
britische Berechnungen aus der
Vorkriegszeit gehen davon aus dass pro
Tonne abgeworfener Bomben mit 50 Toten
und Verletzten zu rechnen ist bei
späteren Angriffen auf London dem
sogenannten Blitz liegt die Verlustrate
bei einem opferprotonne
haben viele Experten gingen davon aus
dass Flächenbombardements die Art der
Kriegsführung revolutionieren würden
doch zielgenaue bombatmos auf Fabriken
oder Eisenbahnlinien sind zu dieser Zeit
noch nicht möglich
[Musik]
entbehrt nicht einer gewissen Ironie das
England die deutschen Luftangriffe durch
orchestrierte Flugabwehr zurückschlug
dann aber so naiva zu glauben dass man
die deutsche Industrie einfach so kaputt
Bomben konnte
[Musik]
eine britische militär-expertise über
die Wirksamkeit von Luftangriffen stellt
im Sommer 1941 fest dass nur jeder
dritte Bomber seine Ladung innerhalb
eines zielradius von 8 Kilometern
abwirft in mondlosen Nächten ist es nur
jeder 15
dementsprechend passen die Briten ihre
Angriffsstrategie an
definiert man eine ganze Stadt als Ziel
trifft man fast immer
[Musik]
es ist der Beginn der flächenbombatmos
am 14 Februar gibt das britische
Luftfahrtministerium den Befehl zum Area
Bombing dem flächenbombert Arthur Harris
genannt bomber Harris ist mit der
Umsetzung der Maßnahme betraut er sagt
der Krieg ist ein Wettrennen dessen
Preis der Siege ist
das Ziel des flächenbombatements wird in
der Area Bombing Directive klar
definiert
die Angriffe gelten der Moral der
feindlichen Zivilbevölkerung im
Mittelpunkt stehen die Industriearbeiter
Harris glaubt fest daran dass man
Deutschland durch Bomben Terror in die
Knie zwingen kann er spekuliert darauf
dass ein bombatmont von Industrieanlagen
und Wohngebieten Harris spricht wenig
zimperlich von enthusung früher oder
später das Kriegsende herbeiführen würde
für die deutsche Bevölkerung gibt es
einen einfachen Weg diesen Härten zu
entkommen sie muss nur raus aus den
Städten ihre Arbeit ruhen lassen und
hinaus aufs Land gehen um das heimische
Feuer aus der Ferne betrachten zu können
[Musik]
1942 fließt ein Drittel der britischen
Militärausgaben in die Finanzierung der
flächenbombats ein weiteres Drittel wird
für die Produktion schwerer Bomber
ausgegeben
[Musik]
es stellte sich jedoch bald heraus dass
die alliierten Bomben nur die
Entschlossenheit der deutschen stärkten
bombensatt
für mich ist das nur schwer
nachvollziehbar ich habe zahlreiche
Berichte von deutschen gelesen die die
Bombardements erlebt haben das ist ein
Albtraum wie man ihn sich schlimmer
kommt vorstellen kann
die Airlines und die Luftangriffe der
Alliierten prägten zunehmend den Alltag
der deutschen
insbesondere ab 1942 war die vor die Tür
seit dieser Zeit nahm die Zahl der
Angriffe und die Intensität der
Bombardements zu intensity of bombing
[Musik]
Essen wird in der Nacht vom 8 auf den 9
März bombardiert am 28 und 29 März
greift die Royal Air Force Lübeck an
234 Maschinen werfen mehr als 400 Tonnen
Bomben über der Hansestadt ab
Lübeck brennt
320 Menschen starben
[Musik]
1468 Gebäude werden völlig zerstört
die prächtige mittelalterliche Stadt
liegt in Trümmern
[Musik]
wurden erst in letzter Minute ausgewählt
an Weihnachten bombardierten wir eine
kleine Stadt in der angeblich Munition
gelagert wurde es war eine Schande
Deutschlands Antwort auf die Zerstörung
sind die sogenannten bedecke Angriffe
benannt nach dem gleichnamigen
Reiseführer der bei der Auswahl
historischer britischer Städte zu Rate
gezogen wird
Harris dreht daraufhin weiter an der
eskalationsschraube am 30 und 31 Mai
schickt er erstmals mehr als 1000 Bomber
gleichzeitig in die Luft
[Musik]
das Ziel seines Angriffs ist Köln seine
Mission klar umrissen
das Ziel die Stadt Köln zu zerstören
wenn wir erfolgreich sein wollen müssen
wir dem Feind einen Wirkungstreffer
verpassen den er nicht vergisst geben
wir es ihm direkt aufs Kind
so viele Flugzeuge habe ich in meinem
Leben noch nie gesehen ich blickte hinab
auf das Zielgebiet und sah nur noch ein
Flammenmeer
zu Kriegsbeginn hat Köln mehr als
750.000 Einwohner
im März 1945 sind es nur noch 40.000
zwei Tage nach dem Angriff auf Köln wird
Essen mit der gleichen Härte angegriffen
Ende Juni ist Bremen das Ziel
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich dass der Himmel voller
Flugzeuge war das war ein unglaublicher
Anblick die wirkungsvoll das letztlich
war weiß ich nicht
in der Nacht vom 24 auf den 25 Juli 1943
wird Hamburg von den bis dahin
schwersten Luftangriffen der Geschichte
getroffen
der Name der Operation ist Programm
Gomorra
es ist eine neue Dimension der
Vernichtung eine Fläche von 250.000
Quadratmetern steht in Flammen
ein Feuersturm mit bis zu 1000 Grad
Celsius wird entfacht
auch Wolf Biermann hat das Inferno in
Hamburg erlebt
über uns der Weltuntergang und im Keller
saßen die Leute wie die Tiere es war
bald klar dass wir nicht mehr rauskommen
weil die Glut schon die Kellertreppe
herunterkoch
es gibt Berichte wie das die Kampfmoral
der Soldaten beeinflusst hat sie sagten
wir kämpfen einen aussichtslosen Kampf
an der Front und zu Hause werden Frau
und Kinder aus ihren Häusern gewonnen
eine 15-jährige beschreibt das
traumatische Erlebnis Mutter wickelte
mich in feuchte Tücher sie gab mir einen
Kuss und sagte Lauf
doch kaum ein Pilot zweifelt an der
Rechtmäßigkeit der Mission
wir fragten uns nicht einen Moment ob
wir das richtige Taten niemals
die Luftangriffe auf Hamburg zerstören
vier Quadratkilometer Fläche und
produzieren knapp 43 Millionen
Kubikmeter Trümmer
die Bewohner hinterlassen verzweifelte
Botschaften auf den Trümmern wir leben
Hilde wo bist du
während des Feuersturms in Hamburg
sterben mehr als 34.000 Menschen
[Musik]
31.647 Leichen werden geborgen die Royal
Air Force fliegt
3.095 Angriffe und meldet 57 verlorene
Flugzeuge die USA Fonds absolviert an
zwei Tagen insgesamt 235 Tageseinsätze
und verliert 15 Maschinen Winston
Churchill und Lord KC sehen sich
Filmaufnahmen der zerbomben deutschen
Städte an
plötzlich blickt Churchill mich an und
fragt sind wir Tiere treiben wir es zu
weit
die British bombing Server unit
konstatiert dass die verheerenden
Angriffe auf deutsche Städte nicht den
gewünschten Effekt haben trotzdem werden
sie fortgesetzt nach dem Angriff auf
Hamburg soll Albert Speer damals
rüstungsminister gesagt haben noch sechs
solche Angriffe und der Krieg ist zu
Ende
[Musik]
s es war unübersehbar für deutsche
Zivilisten und Wehrmachtsangehörige dass
sich das Blatt im Krieg gegen sie
wendete
[Musik]
Japan wird von den flächenbombatements
noch härter getroffen als Deutschland
das Time Magazin schreibt zynisch
[Musik]
sobald der Krieg in Europa beendet ist
wollen die USA all ihre Ressourcen gegen
Japan einsetzen
vor allem die beatwine hinein super
Fortress das Langstreckenflugzeug ist
der größte Bomber des Zweiten Weltkriegs
300 von ihnen starten und ihr
vernichtendes Werk zu verrichten
auch am Himmel treffen sie sich und
nehmen mit ihren nadeldünnen rümpfen
Kurs auf Japan
[Musik]
am 9 märz 1945 werfen 346 B-29 Bomber
1665 Tonnen Bomben über Tokio ab
die traditionellen japanischen Häuser
die aus Holz und Papier bestehen werden
von den Flammen verschlungen mehr als 41
Quadratkilometer Tokios brennen
lichterloh nach offiziellen Schätzungen
sterben mehr als 130.000 Menschen
niemand kennt die genauen Opferzahlen
klar ist jedoch es ist der tödlichste
einzelangriff während des Zweiten
Weltkriegs
[Musik]
ein Feuersturm wälzt sich durch Japan 66
Städte werden durch Fliegerbomben
ausgelöscht mehr als 250.000 Gebäude
werden komplett vernichtet über eine
Million Menschen verlieren ihr zu Hause
Schäden sind auf die Brandbomben
zurückzuführen auf 75% der Stadtfläche
steht kein Haus mehr
major showji Taka Hashi beschreibt Tokio
nach dem Luftangriff
ein Schlachtfeld schlimmer verwüstet als
alles was ich mir je vorstellen konnte
[Musik]
in ganz Japan werden 67 Städte
bombardiert Millionen Menschen sind auf
der Flucht
im Sommer 1945 gehen der b-209 Flotte
allmählich die Ziele aus
[Musik]
japanischen Städte standen vor dem
Kollaps die Bevölkerung litt an
Krankheiten die durch die grassierende
Unterernährung noch verschlimmert wurden
alte und junge drohten zu verhungern
[Musik]
gibt es für die Bomben die auf Japan und
Deutschland fallen eine moralische
Rechtfertigung
noch heute wird diese Frage kontrovers
diskutiert und noch heute haben
Historiker Moralphilosophen und
Völkerrechtler keine abschließende
Anfahrt darauf gefunden
[Musik]
fakt ist alle Seiten haben bombardiert
alle glaubten die tödlichen Luftschläge
würden ihn den Sieg bringen
erst als der Krieg vorbei ist werden
auch die Luftangriffe eingestellt
[Musik]
anfang 1943 beginnt eine Reihe von
Konferenzen um die Weichen für den
weiteren Kriegsverlauf und die
Nachkriegszeit zu stellen am 14 januar
1943 treffen sich Winston Churchill und
US-Präsident Roosevelt in Casablanca
es geht um die Verteidigungsstrategie
für dieses Jahr in dem der Feind an
neuen Fronten geschlagen werden soll
nach Abschluss der Gespräche erklärt
rosewelt der Presse
Frieden wird es erst geben wenn die
kriegsmächte Deutschland und Japan
komplett ausgeschaltet sind
Browser Wels Aussage stellt klar dass es
keine Friedensverhandlungen mit
Deutschland geben soll während die
konferenzkaravane nach Kairo weiterzieht
kämpfen die alliierten Truppen weiter
auf europäischem Boden am 10 Juli
beginnen alliierte Streitkräfte von
Nordafrika kommend mit der Invasion
Siziliens im Rahmen der Operation Husky
gehen 115.000 britische und kanadische
sowie 66.000 US-Soldaten an Land nach
einem Monat erbitterter Kämpfe können
sich 60.000 italienische und 40.000
deutsche Soldaten aufs Festland retten
anders als die Briten 1940 in Dünkirchen
gelingt es den Deutschen ihr Material in
Sicherheit zu bringen sie nehmen mehr
als 9000 Fahrzeuge sowie er gesamtes
Arsenal schwerer Waffen mit
der Wall findet in Teheran die nächste
Konferenz statt beim Treffen der großen
Drei ist erstmals auch Josef Stalin mit
von der Partie
eine großartige Konferenz die die
Vernichtung der deutschen Streitkräfte
innerhalb kürzester Zeit zum Ziel hat
hier sehen wir einige der Männer die das
gewährleisten sollen
ist auch in anderer Hinsicht interessant
denn hier zeigt sich das Roosevelt
bereit war Churchill zur Seite zu
drängen um Stalin zu demonstrieren dass
die Amerikaner nicht mit den Briten im
Gleichschritt marschierten
das erkenntnisnahme
Rose Welt glaubte offenbar dass er
Stalin manipulieren könnte tatsächlich
war Stalin aber der gewiefteste von den
dreien ein Meister knallharter
Diplomatie
skizziert seine Pläne für Operation
Overlord die Landung der Alliierten in
der Normandie Stalin ist begeistert
letztlich war es auch ein weiteres
Beispiel dafür dass das amerikanische
Motto lautete Europa zuerst
stalin hatte lange auf eine zweite Front
gedrängt Churchill dagegen nennt sie die
verdammte zweite Front
i think Churchill wanted Churchill den
Tag hinauszögern an dem er seine eigenen
Soldaten gegen die extrem abgehärteten
nazi-divisionen ins Gefecht schicken
musste
1944 wird die verdammte zweite Front
Realität
doch das Jahr beginnt mit einem
entscheidenden Feldzug am anderen Ende
der Welt
[Musik]
in einem Land über das die Welt nur
wenig weiß
Firma